of all the questions we had
the one that came up most often
was
ask benedict to say the word penguin
what is this about well apparently i got
it wrong repeatedly in the documentary
and now i'm completely terrified of the
words um i don't go near it the first
one you sort of get away with and then
after that you lose all sense of what
yeah
let's let's have a look listen carefully
and the last thing you might expect to
see here
[Music]
is penguins
these are fjordland crested penguins
named after this corner of south new
zealand
so why are these woodlands so attractive
to penguins
a fresh water stream through the forest
makes a handy highway for a parent
penguin heading home from a fishing trip